[Applaudissements]
après la Bulgarie et la République
tchèque volodymir Zelenski mais le cap
vers la Turquie à Istanbul le président
ukrainien doit s'entretenir en tête à
tête avec rejet taille hyper douanes il
est de dirigeants participeront
également à une série de réunions
multilatérales au centre des discussions
l'exportation de céréales dès les
premières semaines de la guerre en Kara
a joué les médiateurs entre Russie et
Ukraine pour permettre à Kiev d’exporter
ces marchandises dont le monde entier
des efforts qui ont permis la signature
d'un texte en juillet 2022 sous l'égide
des Nations Unies mais Moscou à
l'intention de ne pas prolonger l'accord
au-delà de son terme le 17 juillet une
possibilité qui fait planer le spectre
d'une grave crise alimentaire alors que
l'Ukraine exportait les trois quarts de
son blé avant l'invasion russe
la Turquie espère toujours renouveler
l'accord en profitant de ces bonnes
relations avec les deux belligérants
ankara a toujours soutenu l'Ukraine
contre l'agression russe et une a eu de
cesse de lui livrer des armes mais dans
le même temps rejet a maintenu le lien
avec le Kremlin dans la droite ligne de
la croissance des échanges commerciaux
entre les deux pays la Turquie et
notamment dépendante de la Russie pour
ses approvisionnements en énergie à
quelques jours du sommet annuel de
l'OTAN zellens qui est erdohann devrait
évoquer le processus d'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'alliance le président
ukrainien le sait il aura besoin de
l'accord de son homologue turc qui
bloque l'entrée de la Suède dans le
temps depuis plusieurs mois